l'émission a démarré tard comme je le
dit et on va vous montrer les stricts
fallait pas manquer donc l'émission a
commencé à zéro heure 6 il a fallu
attendre 0 heure trente trois pour voir
l'interview d'eric zemmour et dès le
début lors de la première question le
ton a été donné par laurent ruquier
qu'il envoyait une petite punchline
santé clos en brique et je pense qu'ils
étaient contents mais avec eric zemmour
mécontent de ne plus le revoir pendant
un moment et de le revoir sur un plateau
regarder
[Musique]
avec votre homme vous êtes là pour nous
présenter votre livre la france n'a pas
dit son dernier mot aux éditions
rubempré on va en parler longuement il
ya beaucoup de choses à dire mais
d'abord on à qui devons-nous ce soir on
invite au réalisme à un commentateur
politique on a un homme politique un
candidat à la présidentielle vous êtes
qui ce soir je suis avec zemmour mais en
connaissait depuis 15 ans au moins
écoutez moi j'ai l'impression que je
suis toujours le même je dis toujours la
même chose qui désespère certains ça
c'est vrai on peux pas vous le reprocher
à la gent temps la même chose depuis
plusieurs années au moins je ne me
contredis pas ce qui est par exemple
pour laquelle au bout de cinq ans j'en
ai eu assez mais où je comprends bien
ça ça démarre avec un laurent ruquier
sourire oui je vous le dis le à qui il a
tourné c'est là que j'ai vu l'homme de
télé je vous jure que c'est vrai et je
connais bien laurent wauquiez maintenant
depuis des années et on sait on s'est
retrouvé en face sur des eaux à la radio
s'est retrouvé en face à la télé il ya
eu une petite friction entre nous
maintenant et je le dis on s'entend très
bien avec laurent j'aime beaucoup je
suis pas d'accord et put sur plein de
choses et notamment sur voila je suis
pas d'accord avec plein de choses aussi
avec eric zemmour même encore plus
qu'avec laurent ok mais c'est vrai que
voilà samedi soir on sentait qu'il était
sympa au début mais quand eric zemmour
lui a parlé des audiences télé là ça a
coincé elle a prévu m alors on peut le
charrier sur une sauf sur les audiences
et je vous jure est et c'est là que je
me suis rendu compte c'est une bête de
télé laurent il pense à ces audiences il
vit pour les audiences et je les ai vus
quand il a piqué sur les audiences là il
s'est dit ce soir là je vis le
fracassant
triomphe médiatique assez news n'arrange
pas mes affaires ça les chevilles eric
quel triomphe mais c'est un triomphe par
rapport aux autres chaînes d'info mais
par exemple nagui à la même heure chaque
soir sur france 2 fait trois fois plus
d'audience que vous faîtes fausse de est
là depuis 50 ans quand je suis arrivé
la tranche horaire faisait 80 mm
réacteurs on est entre 800 mille et un
million tout c'est vrai moi j'appelle ça
un triomphe est vrai que quand j'étais
chez vous on faisait beaucoup plus c'est
vrai vous faites maintenant moins que
moi non c'est plus que manon à balleroy
serait de 700 milles la semaine dernière
je faisais je paie 800 me sens sale en
omettant dsi c'est intéressant parce que
les vous vous avez une chaîne qui est là
depuis cinq ans et ça c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites parce que ça prouve
que manifestement vous ne connaissez pas
bien les chiffres bas voiliers et
j'espère qu'en économie vous serez
meilleurs que ça oui oui on fait à peu
près en ce moment le même nombre de
téléspectateurs je suis d'accord avec
vous sauf que vous voulez faites à 19h
en effet vous avez vu leur entre minuit
et 2 heures du matin c'est incomparable
ce qui compte c'est la part de marché à
cette heure-ci fait combien de personnes
sur cent qui regardent la télévision
vous regarde vous faites 5% on en fait
deux ou trois fois plus ma mère ma mère
voilée est énervé par ça parce qu'elle
est très énervé sur les audiences
également je vais répondre à laurent et
je vais répondre à eric zemmour sur les
audiences comme ça je peux vous donner
une réponse pour moi qui est claire je
vous le dit eric zemmour ce n'est pas un
triomphe c'est un énorme le tri news il
faut savoir que la chaîne est et à cent
mille téléspectateurs il a porté cette
tranche avec christine d'ailleurs qui
est excellente entre 800 et 1 million de
personnes bien sûr il faut savoir
également que laurent ruquier là ils
comparent viennent beaucoup d 1 kg de
patates avec un kilo de café ça n'a rien
à voir puisque il compare une émission
qui passe à une heure du matin qui a une
concurrence bien moindre que le 19
heures 19 heures carrefour d'audience où
il ya le plus de concurrence ou irrigué
moore a réussi à se tailler une place
voilà et qui fait 700 milles de moyenne
4% ce qui est énorme il faut savoir
aussi que la moyenne de la chaîne ces
news la moyenne elle est à 1,8 ce qui
veut dire que eric zemmour fait plus du
double de la moyenne de la chaîne et sur
cible les cibles qui intéresse
énormément les annonceurs voilà il fait
du trip ou du truc laurent wauquiez
alors l'émission marche de mieux en
mieux c'est bien et je suis content pour
lui mais c'est vrai que à une heure du
matin la concurrence est bien moindre et
en plus on va pas se mentir là il est
tous les jours eric zemmour donc tous
les jours 700 milles ça fait énormément
de monde que une hebdo à 600-700 minus
que c'est la moins de 700 mille huit
cent mille c'est bon - donc voilà c'est
vrai que là il ya dix mois mais on va
pas se mentir là le ceo eric zemmour qui
avait raison la culture in motion et
c'est un énorme triomphe nicolas
pernikoff il faut également ajouter
quelque chose pour être honnête c'est
que l'access oui
exactement derrière vous avez les
journaux pour certaines chaînes l'appui
yann c'est tout le monde rêve d'avoir
200 300 400 mille téléspectateurs
regardant passer de 100 milles à 900000
incroyable pense que peu de gens sont
arrivés à faire un tel score après ce
qu'il faut c'est comparer les deux mais
laurent aurait mieux fait de revenir sur
les missions pour tous sur france 2 à
l'époque en 2014 où il avait terminé
d'ailleurs en dessous d'un million et je
vais même vous dire un truc je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez vous étiez sur dix
huit nationalités anglaise passait à ce
moment là c'était assurément pas du 14
mars devrait passer devant donc s'il
avait été honnête intellectuellement ci
l'aurait comparé ça après effectivement
quand vous êtes en s2 sur france 2 la
deuxième partie de soirée par les
parents pardon sur france 2 vous savez
bien qu'il ya pas de concurrence
vraiment dangereux heureusement
heureusement qu'il fait 16 % maintenant
c'est vrai qu'il faut reconnaître aussi
autre chose c'est qu'il a démarré très
très tard puisque l'émission d'avant a
duré quand même 200 minutes et il a pris
l'antenne à 00h40 avec les règlements il
aurait fait beaucoup plus sinon il
appartient il est inédite et
alors on revient donc sur léa salamé
banksy on va pas rester deux heures sur
les audiences n'auraient on vous l'a dit
qu'il ya des raisons pour nous c'est
eric zemmour là dessus vous êtes
d'accord avec nous et rigoler non
l'emballage est indiscutable sous la
thématique voilà c'est tout oui non faut
comparer ce qui est comparable c'est
beaucoup plus fort de faire 700 milles
sur ces news à 19 heures que de faire
800 milles sur france 2 pour parler des
chaînes de télé aussi il ya france 2
c'est bête à dire mais c'est la 2 alors
sur un signe c'est beaucoup plus loin il
faut aller bien content qu'ils vont s'en
suit avec 13 ans doit parler quand même
du fond du sujet enfin je veux dire le
concours de guingamp entre deux
présentateurs c'est pas
tant la str6 fin je vais me [ __ ] a dû
rentrer dans ce débat là d'enfoncer au
ps non c'est vrai que c'est ce que
disait un dollar en d'autres termes
mémona hintermann d'autres termes mais
c'est ce qu'elle avait l'air de me dire
gay que ça c'est une intéressante mais à
moi je trouve ça personnellement que ce
débat aurait pu se produire dans un café
chez eux l'accord ne concernait pas le
public vraiment comme une grande partie
de leurs débats c'est des histoires de
copains d'avant ne sont plus d'accord
qui ne sont plus sur la même longueur
d'onde et qu'entre crédit oui ça a duré
cinq ans j'ai mis du temps mais il a
fallu cinq ans pour se rendre compte de
ce que disait eric et moi sur ce plan là
moi je dirais que zemmour - a eu
l'honnêteté de ne pas cacher ce qu'il
pensait et il a fallu cinq ans pour le
débusquer alors je trouve ça un peu
préoccupant exhale l'audience a aussi ok
on va pas se demander et laurent voilà
et moi je le dis à laurent il a pris
aussi réglé bourg sur sa deuxième avis
sur la saison savait que ça allait
battre l audience aujourd'hui je vous le
dit eric zemmour c'est un booster
d'audience et c'est vrai que tu dis
qu'il arrive sur un plateau on sait que
l'audience va décoller et ses bourdes et
voilà on le sait parfaitement il faut
dire les choses alors la tension n'est
pas redescendue entre les deux hommes
puisque quelques minutes plus tard ils
sont revenus sur la fin de leur
collaboration dans on n'est pas couché
eric vous allez intervenir là dessus
desquelles je me suis séparé douce et
pas du tout ce que vous écrivez je cite
à eric zemmour sa table est assailli
chaque soir par une cour de bobos de
gauche et de militants gays tout ce
petit milieu parisien scandalisait de
longue date par m provocation mais
comment vous savez qu'il invite à ma
table soient tous les homos ne se
ressemblent pas mais tous les musulmans
se ressent ne permet à toutes les femmes
ne seraient pas et je peux parler c'est
tellement choqué je fais tellement chaud
que de déformer la réalité ça de fait
noir aux gens que bon si vous voulez je
m'en vais pas en parler tout seul et ça
eh bien ça vous dérange évidemment ça ne
dérange pas du tout quand vous revenez
en présence d'ailleurs de léa salamé
pour la promotion de votre livre le
suicide français vous dites qu'on a avec
catherine barma ce soir-là faire un
tendu un piètre ne serait pas compliqué
si on vous invite pas c'est de la
censure si on vous invite c'est un piège
ah non non non j'étais ravi que vous
méritiez bon j'explique simplement que
c'était amusant parce que le plateau
était composé avec des gens que j'avais
on vous dit les mots et en liège j'ai
écrit le tribunal alors c'est vrai que
voilà là l'échangé est assez animée eric
naulleau vous étiez avec eric zemmour à
l'époque non mais moi tout ce que vous
dites là dessus et on m'a déplu dans cet
échange d'accords toujours avec laurent
comme mort-né j'suis prénommé du temps
donnait pas couché il y avait quelqu'un
sur le plateau qui était d'ailleurs
laurent ruquier qui d'abord posé le
débat une équipe qui on entrait pas tout
de suite dans le catch à tour là il y
avait une animosité tels que il n'y a
pas eu on n'a même pas su de quoi parler
le livre ça a été immédiatement des
attaques personnes ensuite laurent a
entièrement privatisé le débat il a été
question de leur audience il a été
question de ce que dit eric zemmour sur
sa précédente visite sur le sur le même
plateau ça tournait vraiment à quelque
chose de personnel duquel on était exclu
et enfin laurent ruquier la donne la 10e
- jordan j'aime beaucoup aussi mais
c'est la dixième version contradictoire
sur la raison pour laquelle nous a mis à
la porte ça change tous les six mois
tous les six mois il ya une version
différente là maintenant il en avait
marre d'entendre zemmour ou alors
c'était il voulait plus lui donner la
parole sur un plan politique moi je
trouve que ça a été ratée d'un bout à
l'autre parce que on en a pas eu pour
notre argent on en a pas eu pour notre
attente on a vu un règlement de compte
entre deux hommes qui auraient pu le
faire dans un tout autre contexte alors
dans un instant varenar bien sûr sur les
sujets d eric zemmour de ses news il
n'était pas là aujourd'hui à 19 heures
christine va nous raconter tout ça on
aura la réaction en exclusivité d'eric
zemmour pour touche pas à mon poste mais
c'est vrai que tout au l'émission il ya
eu des tacles laurent il voulait se
faire eric zemmour samedi soir en direct
c'est ça oui moi je crois que il a
essayé de régler un problème qu'il a
avec lui-même delà de la pire des façons
laurent a dit je regrette d'avoir donné
la parole pendant cinq ans à eric
zemmour il le réinvite donc il faut
faire oublier cette contradiction
comment la faire oublier en étant
agressif et c'est devenu tout de suite
vindicatif on reproche pas un
journaliste politique qui lui a reproché
par exemple de beaucoup déjeuner en
ville c'est le boulot un journaliste
police politique mange avec les hommes
politiques ou avec les femmes politiques
c'est comme ça qu'ils obtiennent des
renseignements ou qui font leur métier
donc c'est on attend vraiment sa tasse à
pinailler sur des petits détails ça
manquait complètement de hauteur ce
n'était pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on
nous avait annoncé on a tendance à ce
qu'ils avaient dans le livre vous a fait
partie de compile d'état regardez
je passe mon temps à écouter le recul ça
va à ces personnes qui vont
du bien où est le vrai projet politique
et l'ehpad ans libre en tout cas quand
on lit votre livre on comprend qui vit
dans une bulle et dans un petit milieu
vous avez une image fausse sur un voyage
surtout ne faut pas croire la presse
avait bien sûr tout cas c'est vous qui
est clean de laurent ruquier petit napo
non à banon c'est vous qui écrivez
n'apparaître vous arriver n'importe quoi
dit moi je ne fais que vous dire alors
on va revenir sur l'interview et il ya
un moment voilà où café énormément fait
rage il ya deux grands moments sur
l'équipe de france et sur les prénoms et
noms français voilà puisque eric zemmour
a précisé que s'il était élu s'il se
présentait bien entendu il prendrait des
mesures fermes notamment d'interdire les
prénoms musulmans en prénoms dits
principal regarde il nous est président
j'aurais tapis la loi de 1803 français
n'a pas le droit d'appeler son fils
maintenant un enfant qui s'appelle
mohamed moi je trouve que au bout de
trois générations c'était la troisième
génération je trouve ça triste il
s'appelle encore mohamed parce que
normalement les générations précédentes
d'immigrés changer leur prénom j'ai il
n'y a aucune raison que les nouveaux ne
le fasse pas ça fait rêver qu alors éric
ces scandinaves
est alors votre meilleure émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rajhi sur les propos d'eric zemmour on
sait que si vous avez du mal à vous êtes
c'est complètement à l'opposé voilà dit
là je veux qu'on reste sur lyn thériault
et télévisuelle face à la baie eric
zemmour oui finalement grâce enfin je
suis pas d'accord avec toi eric parce
que là ce moment là précisément moi je
trouve qu'on voit ou pas cyril zemmour a
une stature d'homme d'état parce que
justement il reste dans ce côté
polémiste en fait il n'a pas la stature
d'homme d'état il est toujours dans sa
fixette la france et dans le caniveau si
on est dans le caniveau sa cause des
immigrés donc voilà donc il ressort son
éternel manège et je trouve que
justement est requis et es salaam et ont
bien fait le job parce que justement il
en piégé ils ont montré aux quêtes et
polémiste et mieux sur une heure combien
de
alors mais il ne pouvait pas gagner tout
déballer les présentateurs les
journalistes c'était impossible avec un
homme comme zemmour ils se connaissent
en fait pour le public qui les regarde
je suis pas partie de leur monde du tout
mais du tout le jeu moi je t'ai
reportage était un moment d'ailleurs
quand on les regarde on se dit bon voilà
ce sont des copains d'avant oui en effet
ils sont en train de régler des
problèmes il m'a dit si tu m'as dit ça
c'est on a on a assisté à une non
émission voilà il a fallu à chaque fois
ils filmaient tôt car il ya dans les
gènes j'ai adoré ce débat je veux dire
pourquoi rouaix d'abord parce que
zemmour est la créature de ruquier il
est sorti de son ventre est donc
retrouver le fils contre le père j'ai vu
moi ce qui est sorti de mon ventre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une espèce de retour de la vengeance du
film ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé 2 je ne
connais pas grand monde finalement pour
avoir regardé souvent l'émission
qu'anime christine je n'ai jamais vu des
gens rentrés dans l'art d'eric zemmour
c'est rarissime laurent a essayé de le
faire enfin mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
nom mais tarde pas confondre
chroniqueurs et invités eh bien je veux
en venir l'arrêter le rsa là où il est
redoutable eric zemmour c'est qui il
joue toujours à domicile il invite des
gens dans son émission chez lui il les
enfers dans son filet dont il connaît
par coeur chaque maille puisque c'est
une maille théorique il a élaboré
d'année en année en fonction d'une
vision du monde extrêmement précise
qu'il est le seul à maîtriser donc en
fait chacun qui rencontrait les zemmour
dans son émission est pris dans une
nasse dans laquelle il ne veut pas
débattre parce qu'il n'en est pas le
propriétaire et là je n'ai pas vu un
journaliste interviewant eric zemmour
j'ai vu deux personnalités avec chacun
leur mauvaise foi qui était sur un
terrain presque neutre parce que eric
zemmour connaît ce plateau il était
d'être avec elle au ranquet pendant des
années eric et connaît par coeur zemmour
est donc pour moi la télé c'est ça la
télé c'est pas une interview de politis
ou du monde d'eric zemmour c'est le
bordel c'est la mauvaise foi abbas est
bien ici alors
mais c'est pour ça que je veux dire j'ai
horreur du direct à la fois des coûts va
de la mauvaise foi et du spectacle
c'était de la boxe c'était du catch
c'était gênerait interview ce que
j'aimerais dire non mais bien sûr il ya
eu des combats extrêmes il ya aussi des
moments importants il a été poussé dans
ses retranchements c'est ce passage sur
les noirs j'ai trouvé une grave s'il en
est encore aujourd'hui sur la france et
non essayer de voir jamais qu'ils
peuvent prouver qu'ils valent passer
regarder
un sujet tabou en france on n'a pas le
droit de s'étonner du nombre de joueurs
noirs dans l'équipe nationale
ça vous dérange encore ah non ça me
dérange pas je passais écoutez-moi
imaginer que la machine est une équipe
du sénégal avec li blanc presque
penseraient les sénégalais on a le droit
de se poser la question il n'y a pas de
question tabou pourquoi je connais
encore le droit voire besoin à sciences
po il ya trop de blancs et pourquoi on
n'a pas le droit d'interroger sur le
nombre de noirs en équipe de france de
foot nous sommes je le réel la phrase du
général de gaulle voix c'est avant tout
un peuple de race blanche 2 religion
chrétienne et de culture gréco-romaine
donc je me dis là il ya un phénomène sur
tout le monde entier en parle
est ce que je veux dire c'est que là où
il ya des grands moments dans cette
émission c'est que contrairement à une
idée reçue zemmour pratiquement jamais
ne le dit la même chose que ce qu'il
écrit il s'en excuse c'est à dire que il
fait mine de ne pas s'en excuser mais
vous ne pouvez jamais lui faire dire
exactement ne veux pas lui faire re
connaître exactement ce qu'il écrit il
ne n'assume pas à 100% ce qu'il écrit
c'est ça qui m'a dérangé j'ai connu un
zemmour brutale qui assumait et là j'ai
vu un zemmour qui se rétracte même si je
fais une résonance dans l'éviction
d'eric naulleau et eric zemmour
tendaient chacun son tour d'eric zemmour
de ces news on a bien sûr toutes les
infos on vous le savez c'est dans le
groupe et on a toutes les infos on a
même une réaction exclusive des
réparations ça inadmissible monde en
parle mais qu'il n'est pas candidat
qu'on lui enlève le charme d'erreur
suivant moi je suis plus à l'aise face
aux temps de parole personne ne lui
interdit de passer à la télévision
simplement non mais ça sonne à définir
la chaussure est décompté et bien c'est
samedi lors c'est scandaleux on va vous
expliquer
aujourd'hui la comptes de campagne il a
été déclaré à la commission des comptes
de campagne donc il ya des affiches en
france il ya les amis
l'équipe de france je regrette le débat
n'a pas été au niveau il fallait que
quelqu'un réponde à zemmour pourquoi il
ya autant de noirs en équipe de france
c'est qu'en france le modèle de réussite
qu'on propose aux noirs c'est plus
d'être footballeur quatre avocats ou
médecins voilà
les effets du titre à vis de lui
répondre quelque chose d'être argument
contre argument mais il était tellement
ivre de leur propre animosité l'un
envers l'autre ceux qui n'arrivaient
plus à trouver les arguments
intellectuels critiques oui moi ce que
je regrette je comprends yann moix
lorsqu'il dit que voilà c'est un moment
de télévision cela dit maintenant que
zemmour on a plus de tampon s'exprimer
il n'y aura que des moments de petites
phrases sans arguments sont là
et sont hélas je souhaitais idée
vraiment d'un grand
dîner pendant toute l'émission j'ai
cherché un arguments contradictoires
aucun argument n'a été apportée ça je le
regrette en fait j'ai cherché on a pris
là il rentre au les jeux terminés dirige
ou dont il était chez ruquier comme
quand il était chez moi il était
chroniqueur il avait le temps de
s'exprimer maintenant il est devenu
invités ils rentrent dans le monde de la
petite phrase et ça je des plans pour il
a fait pour le téléspectateur alors on
va en parler dans un instant juste ils
se sont encore accrochées sur un autre
sujet sur l'économie ce qui
conseillerait eric zemmour c'est loïc le
floch prigent un ancien grand dirigeant
d'entreprise qui serait le conseiller
donc économique du probable candidat à
la présidentielle et rue qui ne comprend
pas pourquoi eric zemmour se fait
conseiller par un homme qui a déjà fait
de la prison regardez ce système une
autre passe d'armes intéressant le prix
jean a dirigé des entreprises que vous
ne pourrez jamais dirigé non mais en
tout cas moi je suis jamais allé en
prison oui moi je prendrai quelqu'un
franchement si j'étais candidat à une
présidentielle comme conseiller
économique je prendrai quelqu'un qui
serait jamais passée sur la carte il
envie vous dit que c'est mon conseiller
économique tous les bons amis et et
c'est un ami et moi je défends ce n'est
pas moral économique c'est quelqu'un qui
discute avec moi économie en tout cas
c'est ce qui a été dit dans toute la
presse est là hercules la rue là là
zemmour reculer il a tort parce que
quelqu'un qui a purgé une peine de
prison a le droit d'être
mick de quiconque ma surprise ont été
invités à inventer pour qu'on puisse se
remettre dans la société comme si on
n'avait pas fait sèchement bien depuis
le début il n'y a pas d' échange
d'arguments la légende je peux vous les
avez trouvé bon ouais moi je les ai
trouvés très bon et beaucoup ont dit
qu'eric zemmour se faisait attaquer
gratuitement moi j'suis pas d'accord
cette interview faut la regarder à la
lumière de l'histoire et la relation qui
lie la lumière on avait besoin à ce
qu'elle
ait à la mer donne en connaissant leur
histoire et leur relation moi justement
ce que ces deux hommes qui malgré leurs
divergences se respecte
on peut demander les règles auxquelles
sont les relations d'eric zemmour avec
la roue il y en a une en vérité je pense
que ne soit pas placée sous le signe du
respect
et se sont parlés depuis le depuis son
éviction de l'émission peu du tout pas à
ma connaissance et puis côté regardez
regardez le ton du débat ce qui est dit
mais le l'embauché mais il sait mais
quand il était chroniqueur ça c'est
intéressant pour et espère qualité leur
relation quand vous étiez chroniqueurs
non mais vous savez avec laurent pour
zemmour il fait la différence entre
l'individu et ce qu'il représente il
peut avoir de la sympathie pour
l'individu ruquier mais pour lui ruquier
s'est tous cas pire c'est le bobo de
gauche c'est vraiment tout ce qu'il
abhorre par l'azeri qu'il dit que rick
est passé journée à daoud effet dîné
avec des homosexuels bobos de gauche les
rares fois où j'ai dîné cru qu'il y
avait pierre bénichou olivier de
kersauson et jacques séguéla pour des
bobos de gauche homo passera à siros
alors mais quelle est l horreur je pense
simplement qu'il y avait eric zemmour
devait prouver sa maxi pour laurent
wauquiez avait eu au téléphone après son
passage chez le roi pour lui il était
assez content que son passage à il a
aimé la façon dont il a été traité ou
pas je côté ça m'embête de fer lors
d'une conversation privée où l'accord
vous avez raison je comprends bon après
il ya le mot traquenard qui a été
prononcée pour s'en priver donc voilà
j'en dirai pas plus bien sûr non mais
c'est quand même à 10 chez enragé qu'est
ce qu'ils voient qu est-ce qui vous a
dire il m'a dit le chien enragé
qu'est-ce qui me lie et vous allez-vous
il était facile de chien est intéressant
de oui oui je le dis je le dis ouverte
bienvenue une victime mais il se
comporte
c'était c'était comment lien et puis
quand nuit mais je dire on sent très
bien comme alayan façon d'interviewer
argument contre argument pas la bave aux
lèvres